muy bien esta vez vamos a resolver la
parte se dice para qué valor de t 0
menor o igual que te menor o igual que 8
es decir que está entre 0 y 8 la
cantidad de agua en la tubería es mínima
justifica tu respuesta bien pues para
esto lo que vamos a hacer es definir una
función una función que voy a llamar a y
esta función
va a representar la cantidad de agua en
la tubería en cualquier tiempo t
entonces va a ser una función que
depende del tiempo y una vez que
tengamos esta función lo que voy a hacer
es buscar el valor mínimo para esta
función a en bueno este intervalo así
que digamos que a bt es decir la
cantidad de agua en la tubería para
cualquier tiempo te va a ser igual y
bueno vamos a recordar cuál es la
cantidad de agua con la que empezamos
hemos escrito justo acá arriba si lo ves
aquí dice que empezamos con 30 pies
cúbicos de agua en el tiempo te igual a
cero así que si regresamos a la pregunta
y una vez que estemos justo por acá lo
primero que voy a escribir son estos 30
pies cúbicos con los que empezamos en el
tiempo de igual a cero ya es donde vamos
a tener que sumar o quitar una cierta
cantidad de agua entonces a esto le
vamos a sumar y bueno le vamos a sumar
la integral desde el tiempo de igual a
cero hasta el tiempo de muy bien porque
ojo observa que esta es una función de
tema y de que tomaremos integral
bueno pues pensemos en nuestro flujo de
entrada en nuestra entrada neta ya esto
lo vamos a multiplicar por un pequeño
cambio en el tiempo así que si sumamos
todos estos pequeños cambios en el
tiempo desde cero hasta t entonces vamos
a tener el club
de entrada agregado así que cuál es
nuestro flujo de entrada bueno pues para
eso vamos a recordar nuestras funciones
que tenemos acá arriba tenemos una
función r que es la tasa a la que entra
el agua y tenemos una función de qué es
la tasa a la que sale el agua y en lugar
de escribir a t
justo aquí voy a usar a x porque acá
abajo estoy usando atem justo aquí en
uno de mis límites de integración que va
a ser nuestra variable que usaremos para
el límite superior de la integral y por
eso vamos a tener una función de tema
entonces me voy a tomar a rd x que es mi
tasa de entrada ya esto le voy a quitar
d de esta variable x que es mi taza de
salida y bueno podemos usar cualquier
variable pero al final la variable
importante stem que nos va a ayudar a
darnos esta función r tx
menos de x ya esto lo voy a multiplicar
por un pequeño cambio en el tiempo de x
de nuevo esta es nuestra tasa neta de
entrada es decir lo que entra menos lo
que sale y bueno a esto lo estamos
multiplicando por pequeños cambios en el
tiempo o en x en este caso y vamos a
tomarnos la suma de todos ellos desde el
tiempo cero hasta el tiempo temp
así que esto nos va a dar cuánta agua
vamos a tener en la tubería en cualquier
tiempo t ahora bien pensemos en qué
punto esta función am toma un valor
mínimo en este intervalo y realmente hay
tres posibilidades en donde puede tomar
el punto mínimo
la primera es tomar el punto mínimo
justo al principio es decir en a de cero
la segunda es que tome un punto mínimo
en el punto final es decir cuando te
vale 8
a de 8 o la tercera opción es que tome
el punto mínimo en algún valor entre 0 y
8 en donde sería un mínimo local en cuyo
caso la derivada de aps sería igual a 0
pero bueno primero qué te parece si
evaluamos a am en alguno de sus puntos
extremos así que empecemos con a de 0 a
de 0 va a ser lo mismo que y bueno esto
ya lo sabemos es lo mismo que pone el 0
aquí en esta integral y tomar nuestra
integral de 0 a 0 o podemos recordar lo
que ya sabemos ya sabemos que en un
inicio habían 30 pies cúbicos de agua
así que en un inicio va a haber 30 pies
cúbicos de agua
ahora pensemos en el otro extremo en am
de otro y bueno esto va a ser lo mismo
que tomar los 30 más la integral de 0 a
8 de bueno de rd x menos de equis y todo
esto multiplicado por de x y para
nuestra suerte tenemos por aquí la
calculadora pero antes de traer la
calculadora déjame subir para camps para
ver las funciones para ver cuánto valen
nuestras funciones y están justo por
aquí aquí ya podemos ver cuánto vale r
dt y ddt ahora voy a traer por acá a
nuestra calculadora la voy a poner justo
por aquí y lo primero que voy a hacer es
definir una función hay varias formas de
hacerlo pero creo que definiendo una
función va a ser mucho más fácil para
poder
con esa función de una manera más rápida
y así poder hacer todo lo que nos falta
entonces la función que voy a definir es
r de x menos de x y si observas aquí
tenemos a erdem así que voy a usar x por
ahora y entonces me va a quedar
paréntesis 20 que multiplica al seno de
y bueno me queda x cuadrada entre 35 x
cuadrada esto lo voy a dividir entre 35
muy bien ya esto le vamos a quitar de de
x que en este caso aquí tenemos la
función de de tema y voy a poner x en
lugar de t entonces me va a quedar abro
paréntesis menos 0.04 por x elevado al
cubo esto que multiplica
es elevado al cubo ya esto le voy a
sumar 0.4 que multiplica a equis elevado
al cuadrado ya esto le voy a sumar 0.96
que multiplica a equis muy bien entonces
tengo r de equis que es 20 por el seno
de x cuadrada entre 35 menos de de x que
es menos 0.04 por x elevado al cubo más
0.4 por x elevado al cuadrado más 0.96
por x muy bien así define esta función
de uno y ahora voy a regresar a este
primer módulo que tengo aquí a esta
pantalla inicial y ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es tomarnos 30
más la integral de la función de uno de
rd x menos de x recuerda que lo que
estamos buscando es justo
esta integral que tengo acá abajo es lo
que quiero hacer esta de aquí la
integral de 0 a 8 de r tx - de x de x es
una integral definida y ya sabemos
hacerlo esto es lo mismo que 30 más y
bueno nos vamos a ir a matt y después
voy a poner aquí en el número 9 la
integral definida le voy a dar entre
justo es lo que queremos de quien bueno
de nuestra variable de 1 así que vamos a
buscar nuestras variables
en este caso aquí tenemos las variables
y voy a poner 1 la función de 1 muy bien
observa que esto nos va a ahorrar
bastante tiempo pues de escribir toda la
función r
x menos de equis pero esto nos va a
ahorrar bastante tiempo y una vez que
tengo 30 más la integral definida de la
función de 1 recuerda que después
tenemos que poner la variable bajo la
cual le estamos integrando que es x y
después tenemos que poner los límites de
integración los límites de integración
es de 0 a 8 muy bien y ahora si tengo
que esto va a ser igual a 48.54 y si
redondeamos me va a quedar 48.54 4 pies
cúbicos así que déjenme notarlo esto es
aproximadamente aproximadamente 48.54 4
pies cúbicos esto claro en el tiempo de
igual a 8 y ahora vamos a buscar un
punto entre estos dos límites que me dé
un mínimo local un punto local
ahora independientemente si es mínimo o
máximo encontraremos los puntos críticos
igualando la primera derivada de am
igual a cero
la primera derivada de a con respecto a
t igual a cero y bueno vamos a encontrar
esta derivada lo primero que tengo es la
derivada de una constante con respecto a
t y bueno eso es cero así que aquí no me
va a quedar nada y después tengo la
derivada de esto que tengo aquí con
respecto a t y eso se obtiene con el
teorema fundamental del cálculo y me
quedaría r de rd - de dt esto porque
aquí tenemos una función ítem es mi
límite superior así que lo que sea que
integremos aquí va a ser una función de
t y ahora para que esto de aquí sea
igual a cero tenemos que averiguar
cuándo r d t es igual
y para nuestra suerte ya definimos en
nuestra calculadora una función que es
rd - de dt bueno en este caso r de x
menos de x así que si regresamos por acá
y ahora vemos nuestra calculadora
para igualar esto a cero lo que hay que
hacer es igualar la función de uno igual
a cero y para hacer eso voy a utilizar
el solberg solver me ayudará a aproximar
soluciones de este tipo de ecuaciones
así que para eso voy a apretar aquí este
botón de más y justo acá abajo de donde
está el número 9 de la integral definida
en el número 0 tengo
solberg así que voy a presionar este y
ahora me dice que ecuación quiero
resolver la ecuación 0 igual y bueno ya
sabemos que queremos hacer y 1 igual a
cero así que me voy a ir a variables
justo aquí en funciones que ya definir y
aquí tengo 1
entonces quiero que la función de uno
sea igual a cero y ahora sí voy a
presionar alfa y después solve y ahora
lo que me piden es un valor inicial para
empezar a buscar así que si aprieto que
empiece a buscar en cero me va a dar que
bueno bueno me dice que cero es una
solución y claro cero era una solución
pero si quiero otro valor que esté entre
0 y 8 no sé se me ocurre empezar a
buscar en dos y ahora pongo al funk y
soul
entonces me da que 3.27 3.27 2 es una
solución de esta ecuación de 1 igual a
cero así que déjame escribirlo
aproximadamente te toma el valor de
bueno 3.27 2 para tener una solución
ecuación y ahora lo que vamos a hacer es
evaluar esta función am justo aquí para
ver si tenemos realmente un punto local
mínimo y de hecho para ver si tenemos
una cantidad menor que a de 0 porque ya
vimos que a de 8 es mayor que a de 0
entonces como hacemos eso bueno lo que
vamos a buscar es am de 3.27 2 y para
eso vamos a regresar a nuestra
calculadora vamos a regresar a nuestra
calculadora y bueno vamos a salir de
aquí así perfecto y ahora lo que
queremos hacer es tomarnos 30 30 más y
ahora vamos de nuevo a más y vamos a
tomarnos el número 9 la integral
definida de quién es bueno de nuestra
variable ya la tenemos aquí nuestra
variable
y recuerda que nuestra variable de
integración es equis y bueno ahora vamos
a tomar los límites de integración el
límite inferior es 0 y el límite
superior va a ser 3.27 2 entonces 3.27 2
y ahora nos dan presiono éste y me dan
27.96 5 aproximadamente 20 7.96 5 así
que voy a quitar mi calculadora y voy a
apuntar que esto es aproximadamente
aproximadamente 20 7.96
y entonces ya estamos listos para
responder para que valor de t la
cantidad de agua en la tubería es mínima
y bueno ya podemos decir que para el
valor de de aproximadamente de 3.27 2
justo aquí tenemos la menor cantidad de
agua e incluso menor que cuando
empezamos que era este valor de aquí y
también menor que cuando tenemos el
tiempo de igual a 8 entonces cuando t es
aproximadamente 3.27 2 tenemos que la
cantidad de agua en la tubería es mínima
y bueno podemos escribir que es mínima
porque a de 3
punto 27 2
esto es menor que a de 0 que a su vez
era menor que a d
de lujo y ojo podríamos haber obtenido
un valor mínimo o un máximo justo cuando
igualamos la primera derivada a 0 pero
como obtenemos un valor más pequeño que
inclusive estos dos nos dice claramente
que este es un mínimo déjame escribirlo
cuando te es aproximadamente 3.27 2
tenemos un mínimo ya está esa es la
respuesta o podemos decir que en 3.27 2
es un valor mínimo